hey guys this is andrew from
tradingsensors.com i've been working as
a professional trader for the past
six years in hong kong on the option
market and i've just started to make
youtube videos because guys i want to
show you how
i do my analysis at work what kind of
tools and techniques i use
and i want to show you how to do it
yourself so in this video
i'm gonna apply different techniques on
amc let's get into it
[Music]
so this is amc chart on the four hours
time frame
like always i start from here and
let's try to make some analysis
the first thing i do is i check if i see
any reactions
on the moving averages so here
i don't have much you know i have the
200 period moving average
but it was broken then it came back
right away
everything that is happening here is
kind of messy for me
so i don't have any clear signal but
what i do have
is a nice signal on the trend lines so
first the right thing to do is to do
some elliot wave counting guys
idiot waves is basically helping you
to determine the market structure
so the market is unfolding in waves i
believe
that and iliad waves is a set of rules
that you need to apply
to make a proper counting that will help
you to separate one wave
from the other one why this is important
because once you have your waves
counting
so here i have accounting that is valid
then you can better use trend lines
so this is for me the most important
thing about idiot waves counting is that
it helps you
to actually properly define your waves
and to
apply uh trend lines breakout on this
waves so here i have a valid counting
that is
making an abc in this uh second wave
so here you have the first wave one two
three four five then correction abc
i am not sure hundred percent this
correction is done uh when i was you
know
around this levels i was telling you
guys you know my i need to see waves
so i was you know saying that i expect
the price action to go
lower and i was telling you guys that i
have a level around 750
that would be probably acting as a
strong support
and we didn't even go there but we went
as you can see here guys
we went to 8 30 which is
below the bottom of wave a so we have an
abc
so all right so for now just by doing
my abc here like this it's possible that
this correction is done then i have my
wave abc here so i can draw
my trend line all right i'm going to do
it again with you guys
once you have your waves you're able to
draw your trend lines
and you connect you know very easy the
highs that you have so let me get rid of
the abc to do it properly
so this high here some people like to
use you know the
closing level of the candle i like to
use the highest level of the candle
but once again you have different
methods and look here when i do this
like this i have almost a perfect
reaction and so you can see guys that
here rebrook this trend line in the so
it was
on the 15th of april at the open so in
my last video i have already told you
guys that we broke this trendline on the
upside
and that it looks good that maybe this
is the sign
that the correction is done and what
happened
the next day is that we retested it
perfectly guys
you know we touched it here and so for
me this is
a very good sign as well so this is a
valid breakout once again guys
when you have a breakout you cannot be
sure hundred percent it will
be a reversal sign but it's
like it's working like i often say
around 80 percent of the time
once you have a breakout that is
confirmed this one is confirmed
80 of the time you're gonna have a
continuation
move in the direction of your breakout
so one positive sign that i have here
then of course the logical
counting would be so a b
c and here guys we would have
our one two
three four five all right so this is
what we
were expecting here if this uh breakout
holds once again for those who want
to know more about idiot wave principle
just click on the link in the
description of this video
and you're going to receive a free video
where i explain everything about
the different rules that you need to
know to use idiot wave principle
and here guys i want to show you
something else so we have this
thing when i use moving averages and
trend line which is for me the basis
that i always use on my charts
then i like to use you know kind of a
different method
but that is very efficient too which is
giving you some information
about is the price action about to
revert or not
and this technique is called divergence
so first let me quickly show you the
different kind of divergence that we
have
so i found this on the internet but i
use divergences a lot
but i thought it would be useful for you
guys to have something visual
so let's focus first on the divergence
we have here
so you have basically two type of
divergence let's forget about the
exaggerated divergence you have the
regular
divergence and the hidden divergence so
let's imagine the market is going higher
so in this situation
but this is your price and this is your
indicator so you can do it with any
momentum indicators or rsi
macd for example stochastic you know all
of the stuff works
but i like to use it with the macd and
it's like
you know helping me a lot but it's
working like maybe 60
of the times so it's not you know a
perfect uh
method but it's just helping so in this
situation so we are not in this one when
the price is going higher
and your momentum indicator is going
lower it means that basically
here the market made a new high compared
to here
but with less power right this is the
power so you can see the power is going
nowhere
when the price is going higher this
means that the market is out of steam
that you don't have the same bullishness
like
bullish sentiment in this high
that you used to have here so it means
that the market
is not strong enough probably to hold
and that it might revert
all right so this is bearish so you have
the same for the bullish case when the
market
is going lower but you can see that the
macd is kicking in
and the macd is going higher then this
is bullish all right so this is the
regular divergence
what what we're having on the amc is a
hidden divergence
we're in this situation because the
market is going higher
you know it's making new highs i mean
higher lows so it's a bit different
that's why it's hidden it's with the
lows
we're having new higher lows but with
the macd
that is intensifying on the downside so
usually
when the macd is you know more negative
the price action should be lower as
actually because you know it means that
there is a lot of bearish momentum when
the mag the
magnesium momentum indicator and it's
trading lower
but the price is actually making a
higher low
so it means that it's bullish that's
what you need
to remember when you see a macd that is
drifting lower
with the price action making higher lows
we
having a hidden divergence and here this
is exactly what we're having
look so it's the same situation the
market is making higher lows all right i
have one low here
one low here so higher
lows but look what the macd is doing the
max is the blue one
that you need to take here into account
the orange one is the exponential moving
average
of the macd itself and the crossover of
those two lines is the macd signal but
the blue line
here is the macd is the one that is
moving the faster
and you can see that the macd between
here and here
so you need to pay attention exactly to
the date 19th of february so from here
to here the market is making
higher lows but the macd is going from
0.2 to minus 0.1 so the macd is going
lower
so i'm not sure you can see it well
okay so here and here
okay so you see this is a hidden
divergence
macd going lower the market making
higher lows so i have two information
coming from from two different methods
yeah i have my trendline method
and i have my hidden like momentum
indicator method
that are telling me the same thing is
that the market is about to revert
so once again guys there is no guarantee
it is still possible so i would give to
this scenario so this is clearly my
preferred scenario and i would give it
seriously a 85 chance of
being good but you always need to have
different scenario in mind so the
bearish
like short-term bearish scenario is that
for example
to invalidate this counting
you need for example to have a second
wave that is going lower here
so if this happens this is this cannot
be a one two three four five all right
so basically the levels you need to
watch is
8 30 if we trade below 8 30 we're
probably gonna go to 7.50
and on the upside for the same reason so
the bearish case is we go here
and it cannot be an abc if the the price
is going
above the b wave here then this cannot
be an abc
because then you would have inside the
abc something like this so this wouldn't
be
valid so for this to be good we need to
see a price action trading above
11 30 and this would validate the
bullish case or
to invalidate the bullish case and to
probably go to 750
we need to see the price trading below 8
30. so
guys that's it for me to sum up the
situation i see
some bullishness coming back here but
once again we don't know if amc is going
to emit more shares
apparently not but who knows we don't
know if some news would
happen so technical analysis is just
giving you
the most likely scenario and once again
guys
always keep in mind that this is only
one scenario
and that everything can happen anytime
so hope you guys enjoyed this video and
if you did please don't forget to click
on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything new
and stay close to show see you guys